hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I hope you're doing very well today
you're looking lovely I love the way you
look you got a new look and I like that
new year new you ah I always find that
slogan annoying because you don't get a
new you the day it turns to a new year
new you takes a lot of hard work and
that's kind of a discipline thing that
I'm committing myself to this year I
talked about this in the 16 million
video but this year I've been doing a
ton of self-improvement stuff I've been
exercising the first thing I do when I
wake up I wake up at 7:20 a.m. and then
I go work out for an hour and then I
take a shower and then I practice guitar
for an hour and then I learned German
for an hour and then throughout the day
whenever I feel like it and then I
record for about 4 hours straight and
that's every single day what what I'm
trying to get at is that you can't have
a new you instantly you can't just
automatically do a new you you can't
wake up one day and say like I'm
different as of today and everyone's
gonna recognize how different and great
I've become it's still a lot of work
motivation is one thing and I said this
on on Facebook and Instagram when I was
doing my sweat updates in the morning
but I said motivation is one thing but
motivation is temporary motivation is
like a feeling you get that fades away
the only way to really get change is to
commit yourself to discipline to
discipline yourself is to commit to
something and make it a habit and hold
yourself accountable for those changes
on a day-to-day basis doing the same
thing every day becomes a habit but it's
harder and harder it's time goes on
because your body resists change and it
doesn't want to change it it's
comfortable where it is so you have to
hold yourself accountable and that's
where discipline overtakes motivation in
a lot of ways and that's kind of what
I'm holding myself to this year I'm not
even trying to like shove it in people's
faces then Hey look at me new year do me
I'm doing a great job at being amazing
which is usually what I do in all my
videos but at least I'm not trying to do
it for what I've been doing there but I
just wanted to mention that it's been
going very well considering that this is
the first week that I've been back and
I've been on this new schedule it's been
going very well for me but how in the
hell am I going to know if I'm gonna
commit to it it's only one weekend but
all things aside it is good to know that
some things do not change with time
and one of those things is Tyler Tyler
is like the immovable object to the
unstoppable force that is the universe
he is a he isn't ever standing constant
in the universe you could measure time
off of that guy's anal baby don't get me
wrong I love Thailand to death like I
don't want to I'm not criticizing him
anyway but he is he is very particular
and if he ever says something that you
might think oh do you mean this he goes
no I mean exactly what I say and I will
defend it to the death even after this
video comes out he will not admit any
sort of misdoing in what he said so we
were all having a little meeting we're
talking about logging stuff and keeping
notes and he said oh you know yeah we
should we should archive all of the
stuff that we do oh yeah yeah archive
you know Oh archive it could be set
either way though
oh no no Tyler its archive it's
definitely archive
no it's heart it could be our drive it's
so a typical Tyler fashion he defended
it to the death as is his wand he's
allowed to do that just like we're
allowed to question it okay so to settle
the debate because we're not normal
humans were Millennials apparently so
Ethan took to Twitter to try to settle
the debate so we asked people to send
video of you guys saying the word
archive and myself I thought how badly
could it go it's probably archived
perfectly fine thank you at Savan array
your wonderful human being
but then og chin comes by and archieve a
archive Rick trick Eve artichokes onions
and
mom subscribe so it it just uh it just
starts to go downhill [ __ ] archive yes
perfectly acceptable thank you for
coming Thank You Evie the human archive
uh-huh Archie Bay no I'm not ready okay
Archie Bay archive yep ed Jovi's or
choice so one for the one for the Tyler
camp there I guess that's pretty good
archive yep archive yep our ship oh oh
they're Turkish okay that's fine that's
understandable if you not a native
English speaker is fine awk I've okay
thank you real luca's Elliot or Chad I
don't know why that's important but okay
it was raw it was wrong I don't know why
it's so funny to me but this is so funny
it's like when I was doing that don't
laughing and the guy was just saying
mispronunciations of the word pregnant
over and over again and for some reason
in repetition is [ __ ] funny so I
picked out a word I actually looked up I
looked up on the list of most difficult
words to pronounce okay so send me a
video of you saying the word worse just
sure Shire I don't even know how to say
that word
we're Chester Shire we're just assure or
Schwartz assure or cease tertiary or
sister genre worships a 10 word where is
Sharon were worried not sister Shire
warts and [ __ ] warts steer me wrong
warts for higher rollercoasters what the
[ __ ] is this what the [ __ ] is this what
the [ __ ] is this worse
no not doing it that's me worst assure
her markiplier is the worst youtuber
that sounds about right
that makes sense if you compare the two
if you put the words right next to each
other I think that's correct
warcasters Shire was one of my
pronunciations like a shy no no that was
wrong for sure sure Shire subscribe
where's your Shire
come on transfer oh btw could Bob be
played too late I got it poked up I got
it
Wersching tired I don't even I can't
even remember when it's forced to shire
penis I am a 12-4 test desire I love the
enthusiasm
oh yeah we are Worchester sure what is
sister - eh-eh
it's probably close enough well done
well done that's good
where's Esther work worsen shot we're
such retired weird voice ters yeah how
about no you [ __ ] walnut I've never
been called a walnut or a walnut were
either of those things but I appreciate
the candor it's pronounced worse - sure
but you spelled it worse Esther Shire so
I don't know what you're on mark well
it's what do you mean that's how it's
how you spell it we're Chester Shire I
don't know who anymore it's for Chester
Shire May what are you on about
adventure annalisa
we're sister shirt built I felt that in
the back of my neck
Jesus forced a shire first shun nudes
mark is a dingleberry well at least
maybe you laugh [ __ ]
nice effort there yes ah if you're
talking about the sauce its
Worcestershire sauce rat uh-huh it's a
city
number one it's a loving Pam number two
versus [ __ ] is that where says Shire
listen you need to [ __ ] go to bed you
[ __ ] bit okay alright let's take that
as my cue to leave
yeah but either way is this a really
funny thing because I it was his this
like hilarious concept and just because
a Tyler is so funny he's so funny in the
way that he is it's like it's just like
is is funny because of how Tyler he I
didn't know if there's gonna be funny
but then again I don't know if it's
actually funny because I laugh it pretty
much anything but I had a good time with
it so either way you know I just want to
do
I just wanted to experiment with this to
see what the [ __ ] was gonna happen with
it and I just giggling like a little bit
but anyway there are a lot of things
that I could do with this that have
audience participation like the point of
this is that it involves you guys in
little simple things that just make
people laugh for no good reason other
than the fact that it's stupid but we're
all collectively stupid so it's funny
'no Stu gether which is good too so I
hope you guys are having a wonderful new
year so far I know it's only a week into
it but I really hope that you guys are
sticking with whatever you guys have
chosen as your new year's resolution
and just remember what I said it really
does not come down to motivation
motivation will leave you faster than
you can imagine it'll be gone like it'll
be gone a couple weeks in and you'll
already be back to the same old ways
it's about discipline and holding
yourself accountable and training
yourself to be better and expecting more
out of yourself putting the goals higher
and higher but incrementally higher
because it's day-by-day progress and
that's the only way that you can
actually be better so I hope you guys
are doing it and remember we are going
to be doing a charity livestream this
month we haven't decided on what or when
but be on the lookout for that it should
be coming more details very soon so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye